in five hours you can roast a pulled
pork you can fly from England to Egypt
or apparently you can play the order
1886 in full as a youtuber has just
proven to the world I'm step forward
with a gamespot news update while you're
all busy smooching loved ones on
Valentine's Day youtuber plainly through
was uploading a series of videos
featuring the entirety of the order 1886
which isn't you out until the end of the
week on febri 20th for ps4 the footage
totals roughly five hours of playtime
including both gameplay and cutscenes
with the time devoted to cut scenes
appearing to be roughly half of that
play time and the cutscenes are reported
to be unskillful the leak has arrived
shortly after rumors circulated that the
game was only three hours long and after
ready at dawn founder and CTO Andrea
passinho responded to a query that the
game was less than five hours long by
stating that was not true later tweeting
that he would no longer comment on such
questions note i am done commenting on
clickbait rumours about game length
downgrade idiocy and such nonsense don't
bother asking another leak from neogaf
user renegade contains a screenshot of
some of the games ultraviolent Gore
effects I'm not going to show it here
because frankly it's pretty nasty so
instead here's a picture of that pulled
pork I mentioned before were you
expecting a longer campaign is five
hours cicely too short for a full priced
game release what did you achieve in
five hours this Valentine's Day let me
know in the comments below and don't
forget to check out our hands-on with
the order 1886 over at gamespot com
you